هو العقل المدبر لاعمال سينمائيه تاريخيه
وافضل ما قدمته السينما العالميه تايتنك
و افاتار تجربه بدات منذ نحو 45 عاما
عندما كان جيمس كاميرون ابن الرابعه
والعشرين ويخرج اول افلام
فيلم خيال علمي قصير تبلغ مدته اثنتين 10
دقيقه بميزانيه 20,000 دولار حصل عليها من
طبيب اسنان واحداث صورها في غرفه معيشه
فوضى مكتمله الاركان لكنها سجلت ولاده
اسطوره هوليوديه وخلال الاسبوع نجح كاميرا
في كسر ارقامه القياسيه نجاح فيلم افاتار
في كسر حاجز المليارات دولار في ارادات
شوباكت تذاكر العالمي افاتار الثاني في
المركز السادس ضمن الافلام الاكثر تحقيقا
الايرادات في التاريخ
الاخرين الجزء الاول
[موسيقى]
ذات يوم يجلس الشاب الكندي جيمس كاميرون
في صاله السينما يشاهد الجزء الاول من
سلسله افلام
بعد ما ينتهي الفيلم وياخذ قرار المهني من
سائق شاحنات يتلقى اجرا يوميا الى صانعه
افلام في اول
الثمانيناتور الذي صدر عام 1984
الجزء الاول كاملا داخل سيارته وبالمناسبه
مع حقوقه بدولار واحد مقابل ان يخرج
الفيلم بنفسه
ما يعادل مليارا ونصف الملياردو لم يكن
الفيلم الوحيد الذي يشاهده كاميرون اثناء
النوم
في طفولته وكتب نصه عام 95 قبل 14 عاما من
اصدار الفيلم قر كاميرا لانتظار حتى تتقدم
تكنولوجيا
ويخرج ويخرج الفيلم للنور كما اراده في
مخيلته وهو الحال نفسه بالنسبه للجزء
الثاني الذي صدر في ديسمبر الماضي تيتانيك
لم ياتي لكاميرا في احلامه لكنه قال انه
نفذه فقط لتمويل حلمه في استكشاف في
البحار واستخدم الفيلم ذريعه لاستكشاف في
حيطان السفينه المنكوبه في قاع المحيط في
2012 كانسر رقما قياسيا خارج السينما حيث
اصبح اول من يصل منفردا لاعمق بقعه في
محيط كوكب الارض المخرج الذي نالت افلام
اثنين واربعين ترشيحا في مسابقات الاوسكار
اليوم اولوياته هي افاتار ربما لنهايه
مسيرته هي مهمته التي ضحى لاجلها بثلاثه
عشر عاما دون ان يخرج شيئا لكنه طور خلال
اربعه اجزاء متتاليه من هذه السلسله انها
تصوير جزءين منها من ضمنها الجزء الثاني
الذي يعرض حاليا في دور العرض اما اخر
الاجزاء فيعرض عام 2000 2018
[موسيقى]